while you're working I have a question
for all of you even as you're touring it
you can see it at these graphs all of
them consist of two things every single
one the same two things on you've got
these red dots what did these red dots
represent these are the data each point
represents one piece of data which is
why they're often called data points
original I know are there are two axes
what are they about
so I heard fugly I have mostly X&Y
that's how they're labeled but what my
Excel why be what could they actually
represent any suggestions yeah okay so
numbers but specifically numbers that
you're maybe measuring or recording
about someone it shows them to variables
so that's why we call this bivariate
done okay as opposed to if you saw like
a child or something like that and
you've got different types of people's
only a single variable but this is two
and each axis represents different so as
I point out there are two objects on
there is the data in red you also get
three things what's that about yeah the
line of best fit or the regression line
or the trend line or the all different
names for the same object by the way
when you've got an object that has got
lots and lots of different names that's
a signal to you that the object is
important to lots of different kinds of
people and they each gear it they're
sort of customary name so I'll call the
line of best fit
so now except that's for those
descriptive name every time you've got
the data you've got to line the data
above the line let's have a look at this
top row you can see as you go from left
to right the light best-fit doesn't
change but the data changes around us
all of these sets of data can have the
same line of best fit what words would
you use to verbally describe how the
data changes as we move from left to
right what words would you use okay I
could say the data gets spread out from
the line of best fit okay everything
used to be right stay on over here but
here just kind of
that fuse our words okay so why can't a
spread are there any other words you
could use to describe it okay so you
could you could describe all of the data
in terms of how closely it hangs to the
line of best fit let me say that if you
you can describe this data in terms of
how closely it aligns with the line of
best fit
okay case you have this started it at
this one as well every single data point
is on the line of best fit bang on okay
here are a few are on it but most of
them are above and below and here I can
count one two three just a handful in
the middle there and most of them are
sort of quite spread out okay so this
word that we are attached to this is a
really important word it's called
correlation so it's actually half the
heading I'm going to give you the second
half of this correlation like the word
suggests is when you've got these
together that are linked right so it co
is whenever you come to you cooperate
and relate me to okay they're linked
together in this line of best fit now in
order to describe this America because
you want to save more than hardly they
are very correlated or they're not very
correlated we attach a none bar to
correlation so we can describe it in
quantitative concrete tasks so what we
talk about correlation the number that's
attached to it is called the correlation
coefficient well now with a daylight
correlation coefficient a sense of all
let us to choose to talk about the
correlation coefficient this is I well
it's not see it's our okay turn on it's
about as good as great as being in which
was Singapore as well okay but I you
will see over and over again if you do
any stats at uni just let it art comes
up frequently this is what they're
talking about is something closely
correlated or is it poorly : so for
example let's go here see how everything
is bang on the line okay this should
have a correlation coefficient of one
okay that's as close as you can get okay
this means everything is pretty much on
to the line of best fit as you get
further and further away from the line
of best fit the correlation coefficient
gets smaller and smaller so for example
this might be here 0.6 this might be
here 0.3 okay you still can't see there
the trend this is not the brand of data
okay if I were to say add a few extra
points on your website if I would
observe this graph into this bit as you
seen before there's a patent to this
just because you have a greater X
doesn't mean anything about your Y value
right see how all of these people have
the same x value but they all have
different Y values so it's like there's
no relationship between these two okay
that will be a correlation coefficient
of 0 no connection or building so R
equals 1 perfect correlation this con
colouration looser correlation but we
can assess these numerically serve it
with not relying on subjective language
now all these things you're going to
give dimension got them all these things
here you can see the trend line the line
of best fit the line of this is going
upward straight as X gets bigger Y also
gets bigger so we call this a positive
correlation as what increases so does
the other
ok so everything's going up and these
positive numbers here tell you it's a
positive correlation so therefore when
you have a look at the bottom half of
the page
yeah ok this perfectly lines up but have
x increases Y decreases
so this is not a positive correlation
like up here this is a negative
correlation however it's still bang on
so ronk on so it still has this value of
one but it's negative indicating it's
going down my point of fixing point
eight which is so yeah I'll show you how
to get like the numbers on this you'll
never get expected to look at a graph
and come up with a number this is
actually calculated in quite a specific
way which I will show you today but this
tells you I okay this gives you an
actual measure for how closely something
is correlated you might see data without
the graph it has to be great for you but
they'll tell you this I'll tell you the
number and then you can technology
they're all consumer there they all
quite they hang together really nicely
if you put a trend line through your
predictions will be highly accurate
whereas over here your predictions have
been quite inaccurate um except sorry a
lot of error that okay so come back to
here in the negative correlation this is
really tight to still one everything is
right on this is still going to be
negative by the blue cell so this might
for instance e negative zero point six
and negative zero point three I'm just
putting on the W so two things that
we're looking for T in terms of the
correlation coefficient number one as
one of it gets bigger does the other one
also get big one like do they get bigger
together if they do it's a positive
correlation so you get these positive
numbers okay ah negative go around
secondly not only might think about the
direction I've also female closely in
crunch okay so they're super super close
you're going to get the correlation
coefficient one as it gets smaller you
get more spread out
let me cuss